ANDREW WALES: Hi everyone.
Welcome to this week's edition
of Behind the Code.
This week we're talking all
about the new Google Analytics
v3 mobile SDKs.
My name's Andrew Wales, I'm on
the Developer Relations team
for Google Analytics.
And with me in studio
is Jim Cotugno.
He's a software engineer who
works on our mobile app SDKs.
And he's been around since the
beginning, more or less.
JIM COTUGNO: Well not quite the
beginning, but pretty close.
ANDREW WALES: Pretty
close, true.
So he's a veteran who worked on
these SDKs for a long time.
And he's been behind a lot of
the changes that are in v3.
So we're lucky to
have him here.
And we'll walk through what's
new, give you some pointers
about migrating, and what
to look for as well.
So if you go ahead and take a
look at the agenda for the
show, I'll give you a quick
overview on what's new.
Then we'll talk a little bit
about get, set, and send,
which are really at
the core of the v3
SDK, these three methods.
We'll talk a little bit about
session management how that
works in v3, what's
changed, and also
what's staying the same.
And then we'll take just a
quick look at Ecommerce,
because the model's changed a
little bit so we want to give
you just a quick heads up
about what's new in v3.
Then also at the end we'll make
time for Q&A. A lot of
you posted some really
great questions to
our Moderator page.
So we'll try to get through as
many of those as we can.
So let's jump right in.
So what's new in v3?
So there's really four main
things that are new here.
The first and probably the most
noticeable thing is that
the APIs are now more
aligned across all
the different platforms.
So you'll notice that Android
iOS and also Analytics.js, our
library for JavaScript, they're
all very much similar
in how you use or how you
get, set, and send data.
And we'll go into that a little
bit further I think.
The second point, second big
thing that's new, is that
there's more flexibility in
setting and sending data.
And we'll go through that as
well later on in the show.
There's now forward
compatibility with new hit
types and parameters.
And we'll show you some examples
of how you can send
any kind of parameter
in the [INAUDIBLE]
SDKs to the GA endpoint.
And then the fourth thing is
that there are some new
debugging features.
Notably, we've added a dryRun
flag so that you can enable
this during testing so that you
don't send test data into
your production reports.
And then we've also replace
the debug flag with this
Logger class, which
is actually a
little bit more flexible.
If you want to learn more about
the debugging features
on this, go ahead and check out
the migration guide on the
developer site, which is
developers.google.com/analytics.
We're not going to cover them
in today's presentation but
there's a lot of documentation
there, so go check it out.
So let's take a closer look
at the first point.
API is now aligned across web
and mobile, across all these
different platforms.
Jim, can you give us kind of
an overview of what the
impetus was for going back and
refactoring to make things
more aligned across these
different platforms?
JIM COTUGNO: What we wanted to
do with this was to kind of
unify the way you do your
tracking calls across GA,
whether you use Android or iOS
platforms for mobile apps, or
whether you do websites.
So we didn't want you to have
to learn a new way of doing
things with each platform.
So we kind of follow the
Analytics.js route with
basically three methods for
your tracking needs--
get set, and send.
That's what you see here.
ANDREW WALES: Cool.
And I think we'll see a bunch
of examples of this later as
we walk through some of
the later slides.
And also, really quickly, I
wanted to touch on the forward
compatibility with
new hit types.
So how does the v3 SDK actually
enable this kind of
forward compatibility?
JIM COTUGNO: So the way it
enables it is it basically
lets you pass in any parameter
name and any parameter value
through the set or
send methods.
And so previously in the
v2 SDK, we had kind of
pre-defined all the parameters
that were enabled for the SDK
to report analytics
data through
the measurement protocol.
So we stripped all that out so
that you could set anything
you want, any time you want.
And this will enable you to add
new parameters, new hit
types, as they become
available in
Analytics in general.
ANDREW WALES: Cool.
So would this also let you,
for example, could you now
send web page views
from the app SDK?
JIM COTUGNO: You could,
you could.
ANDREW WALES: Because
you have the
flexibility to do that now.
JIM COTUGNO: Yes, absolutely.
ANDREW WALES: So that's cool.
OK.
Great.
And actually, here's
just some--
here's an iOS code
snippet as well.
You can just see that--
we'll talk a little bit more
about the dictionary builder
and the Map Builder classes
later in the show-- but just
so you can see a quick example
of how you might set or how
you might send an arbitrary
parameter in v3, and also how
that shows up in the hit that's
generated from it.
Cool.
So now that we've gone through
an overview of what's new,
let's kind of get more
into the meat of v3.
A lot of that is going to be
around using these get, set,
and send methods and
understanding how those work.
So let's start with just
a quick overview.
Jim, can you give us kind of an
understanding of what the
changes from v2?
Because I know in v2 we
had a lot [INAUDIBLE].
JIM COTUGNO: Right, right.
So v2, we originally started
with method calls that started
with track actually,
not just send.
So you had a track view, track
event, track exception.
And then we changed those to
send to be more in line with
what we were doing.
But for v3, as I said before,
to try and align with the
other platforms--
the other client platforms--
we got rid of all those special
purpose send methods
and replaced them with send.
So instead of sendView
we have send.
And you would pass in the map of
parameters or dictionary in
the iOS case that represented
your app you had.
And then same with the
event transaction,
exception, et cetera.
And then set.
We had very specific set
methods for things like
setting campaign, custom
dimensions, custom metrics.
And those all are replaced by
general set method, which will
take the field name
and the value.
And then, forget--
this is a little bit new to
the SDKs in that you could
actually query the values of
the tracker objects that
you've previously set or will be
set for us on your behalf.
ANDREW WALES: So pretty much
any field can be set or
retrieved from the
tracker, right?
JIM COTUGNO: That's correct.
Yes.
ANDREW WALES: OK.
So let's talk, I guess, we'll
start with send, because
that's probably the command
most are going to be using
most often.
How does it work, basically?
JIM COTUGNO: So, send is
very straightforward.
It takes a map for the Android
SDK-- in the iOS SDK it would
be a dictionary--
of parameters.
Parameters have a name and
a value, and they're both
treated as strings.
So we no longer deal with
various object types, like
integers, or floats, or logs.
Everything is a string for the
send parameter-- or the send
method, sorry.
So when you call send, what
happens is the value stored in
the tracker are merged
with the values
provided in that map.
The values in the map will take
precedence over what has
previously set in the tracker.
And then the hit will be
queued for dispatch.
And then you don't have
to worry about it
at that point anymore.
ANDREW WALES: One of the cool
things in v3 that I definitely
wanted to highlight for people
was that it's actually pretty
easy to build these maps of
parameter value pairs, right?
We have these Map Builder
convenience classes.
Could you talk a little
bit about that?
JIM COTUGNO: Yes.
So because we took away the
convenience method calls on
the tracker send event, send
exception, we felt it would be
very useful to provide some
way to conveniently build
various hit types so that you
didn't have to remember which
parameters needed to be filled
in for each type of hit.
And so the Map Builder class was
created for that purpose.
So the Map Builder has create
methods for each of
the common hit types.
And that create method basically
takes all the
parameters that you would
normally set up for that hit.
So for event, for example,
you have category,
action, label, and value.
ANDREW WALES: So as an example,
we have, if we were
sending an event that somebody
touches a button to play a
video, for example, this might
be an example of that.
JIM COTUGNO: Right.
So here's a perfect example
of an event.
There's a couple things to point
out in this example.
One, first off, the Map Builder
actually follows the
Builder pattern.
So those of you familiar with
that pattern will probably
recognize this.
So you create the Map Builder
class using one
of the create methods.
And then you can optionally
set a new additional
parameters.
So here, for example, we're
going to set custom dimension
to a value of watch the video.
And then when you're finally
done with it you can get your
map by calling build.
And then you're all set and
just pass that to send and
you're done.
ANDREW WALES: Cool.
So you can set--
I mean, it's not just this
example's custom dimensions--
but you could set anything else
you need to before you're
ready to build.
JIM COTUGNO: That's correct.
ANDREW WALES: And send
it all in one go.
JIM COTUGNO: That's correct.
Yes.
ANDREW WALES: Cool.
Oh and then here's a--
so it's the same
for iOS, right?
JIM COTUGNO: Yes.
ANDREW WALES: You're building
dictionaries in the class's
GAI dictionary builder.
JIM COTUGNO: Yeah.
So we used to build
a pattern here.
With iOS you don't have maps but
you have dictionaries are
very much the same,
or very similar.
So, yes, same thing.
ANDREW WALES: Cool.
Let's talk about
the set method.
How does that work?
JIM COTUGNO: So when you set,
the step method will make a
permanent adjustment to
your tracker model.
So the tracker keeps track of
all the parameters and their
values that you've set.
It's persistent and it'll stay
in the tracker until you get
rid of it, really.
So that way, if you have certain
fields that you don't
want to set, that you want to
be set on every hit, but you
don't want to set in the Map
Builder every time, you can
simply just call set.
Examples, the value is going
to be persistent.
Tracker, it will show up on hit
unless the map you pass
into your send call overrides
the value.
ANDREW WALES: Right.
Because it'll take
precedence over
what's set in the tracker.
JIM COTUGNO: And if you don't
want to set that value
anymore, what you can
do is pass null--
or nil in the iOS case-- as the
value in that field will
get cleared out, effectively.
ANDREW WALES: OK, cool.
I think it's an important thing
to point out that when
you set something on the tracker
it's going to-- that
value is going to persist sort
of indefinitely until you
destroy that tracker or until
you override that value.
JIM COTUGNO: That's right.
That's right.
ANDREW WALES: So I think, I
know we were talking about
before this.
There are definitely some good
places where you'd want to set
certain values directly on the
tracker that are going to be
applied to a lot of hits.
So one of the examples that I
know we talked about was, for
example, here.
Whenever a viewer screen gets
loaded, it's convenient to set
the screen name first, and then
you can send all your
hits after that.
So in this example, we set the
screen name field to home
screen when the view loads.
And then we're going to send in
app view and we're going to
send an event.
And both of those hits are going
to contain that screen.
And I only had to set it once.
JIM COTUGNO: That's right.
And this is very important.
Just like in the web case, if
you want your events to be
tied to a particular screen,
this is how you have to do it.
Otherwise your events will not
be attributed to that screen.
ANDREW WALES: To a particular
screen, right?
Or I know some other good
examples we're setting
settings like anonymize IP, or
setting a sample rate, because
those are tracker level
settings, right?
JIM COTUGNO: Right.
So when you set those you
probably want them to stay set
for the duration of
your tracker.
ANDREW WALES: Right.
JIM COTUGNO: And so that those
are good candidates for a set
call, a call in the tracker.
ANDREW WALES: And then there
are some bad places to use
this, right?
Places--
basically when you use this to
set fields that you really are
only going to send once, I think
that's probably when
most people will run
into trouble.
JIM COTUGNO: Yeah,
that's correct.
ANDREW WALES: So I know the
example we talked about was an
event action.
So if you have some kind of
handler and you happen to set
an action, or any these event
fields, those are really only
going to be applied--
those should only be
applied to that one event.
But if you set them right and
then send other events, if you
don't provide values--
well, basically you're going to
end up setting those event
fields with every hit, which is
probably not what you want.
JIM COTUGNO: Right.
Yeah.
So this is a bad example of what
you would use the tracker
set method for.
ANDREW WALES: Right.
And then another mistake I know
I made once, you pointed
it out earlier, was--
and we'll talk about the session
control field a little
bit later--
but that would be one.
You have this ability to start
or stop a session by setting
this field.
And if you set that field
directly on the tracker,
you're going to be starting a
new session with every hit.
JIM COTUGNO: Yeah, which
you do not want.
ANDREW WALES: A disaster.
And I made that mistake
so please
don't make that mistake.
Cool.
OK, so the last thing we talked
about, send, set, and
then the last one's get.
JIM COTUGNO: So the tracker is
a model and you could use it
to retain values of the various
parameters that you
want to send to Google
Analytics.
So the get method lets you query
those values that you've
set previously.
So I guess the other point
to bring up here
is that if you haven't--
the tracker has this concept of
what we call default values
for certain fields.
So there's some fields that you
really want to always set
in the application world, things
like the application
name, application version,
the client ID is
another good example.
So we'll fill those in for you
if you don't set them using
the set method, or pass
them through the
map in the send call.
And so if you call get on those
particular fields we'll
give you the value we
will provide if you
haven't set the values.
ANDREW WALES: Right.
JIM COTUGNO: So, for example,
if you want to--
if you're curious to know what
application name we're going
to send with each hit, call get
on the application name
field and you'll see it.
ANDREW WALES: So what about
a field that doesn't
automatically get set, like
if you called get on like
campaign source?
Is it an empty string?
JIM COTUGNO: Yeah.
It'll be, I believe, null.
ANDREW WALES: Null, OK.
JIM COTUGNO: Or nil
in the iOS case.
Correct.
ANDREW WALES: And we should
definitely get a list of those
default values.
We'll make sure to get that
onto dev [INAUDIBLE].
I think right now it's not
there, but we'd like to see
that get posted.
JIM COTUGNO: The final note here
is a client I know set
several folks using the SDK have
asked for us to expose
the client ID that we send.
And we've done that
with the v3 SDK.
There's one very important
caveat here, is all these
calls are non-blocking calls,
except for when you call get
to get the client ID,
you may block.
So especially early in the life
cycle of the application,
you won't want to make this call
in your initialization
code on the main UI thread.
ANDREW WALES: Is that going
to block because
it's reading from--
JIM COTUGNO: Yes, because it's
reading-- the client ID is
persisted on the persistence
store on the device.
And that takes a little
time to read up.
ANDREW WALES: And then lastly,
so, I think throughout as you
call these different methods,
you're going to be providing
fields pretty much
with every call.
So I thought it deserved maybe
just aside to talk about what
these-- like how you access
these fields?
JIM COTUGNO: So yeah.
ANDREW WALES: Go ahead.
JIM COTUGNO: OK.
So we provided some classes that
defined constants for all
the fields that you would
commonly use in the
application tracking world.
And they're in the fields,
that Java class.
There are some examples
there on the slide.
In the iOS, it's the GAI
fields header file.
We've also provided convenience
methods for
creating parameter field
names for custom
dimensions and metrics.
As you know, those are
repeated fields.
They're like indexed.
So you have custom dimension
one, custom dimension two, et
cetera, et cetera.
And so we have some convenience
methods that will
build the parameter name for
you so you don't have to
figure it out for yourself.
ANDREW WALES: And then the last
one is sort of what we
talked about earlier where you
can use this like ampersand
syntax to get, set, or send
any parameters, right?
JIM COTUGNO: Yeah.
So the tracker understands
ampersand syntax.
And so, basically, if you look
at your measurement protocol,
all the parameters there can
be set using the ampersand.
Ampersand t, for example,
would be the hit type.
ANDREW WALES: For a
hit type, right.
So this would be an example
for a new hit type that we
release in the future.
But you could send, as you
said, any measurement
protocol, parameter, this way.
Let's talk about what's new in
session management in v3, and
also what's the same.
Because some things I know have
changed, and some things
are the same.
So, Jim, why don't you walk us
through everything we need to
know, really, about session
management in v3?
JIM COTUGNO: I don't know if
it's going to be everything,
but hopefully we'll
clear the air a
little bit about sessions.
ANDREW WALES: Sure.
JIM COTUGNO: OK.
So, in Universal Analytics
there was a change.
This is like outside the realm
of the app SDKs, but session
management moved from the
clients to the back end.
So the back end for Universal
Analytics, which includes the
v2 SDK and the v3 SDK, the
session management's handled
by the back end.
And the way it does that is it
looks for a gap in time from
one hit to the next.
And when that gap is large
enough, it will declare the
end of session and start
a new session.
So the default value is
30 minutes initially.
And that default value is now
configurable through the
management UI on the Google
Analytics website.
And if you look at the slide,
you'll see a screenshot of
what the page looks
like that lets you
control the session timeout.
Session timeout's kind
of on the upper right
of the picture there.
ANDREW WALES: And then campaign
timeout is there as well.
JIM COTUGNO: Yeah.
Campaign timeout is
there as well.
That's correct.
So in the v2 SDK, in order to
get around that 30 minute
window which was the only window
that the back end would
support initially, we decided to
add support in the SDKs for
controlling sessions.
And we did that through
basically a property or a flag
of session control.
Behind the scenes, what that
flag did was send a parameter
called session control--or
ampersand SC is the name--
and it would send a start
when it felt a new
session should begin.
And what it did is it--
the way we did in v2 is we just
decided that if the app
was sitting in the background
for a certain length of time,
I think the default was 30
seconds, we would set that
parameter up and say, hey,
we need a new session.
We implemented that in
EasyTracker on Android and in
the GAI tracker class that was
returned to you when you ask
for one on iOS.
The other thing to note here is
that when the trackers were
first created in both iOS and
Android, we would also set
that session control parameter
to start and send it
with the first hit.
So that's how it worked in v2
and this was all to give you a
finer control than that 30
minute window, which is what
initially was the only
way you could break
sessions in the back end.
So given now that you
can parameterize--
you can control that window to
a great degree with the UI,
management UI, in the
application, the Analytics
application--
we decided to kind of step
back from it in v3 and
clean things up.
If you want to flip over
to the next slide.
So in Android, in V3 for
Android, the tracker class is
no longer going to set the
session control parameter to
start, ever, for you.
You could do it yourself, it's
just another parameter.
You can--
again, don't use the
set command.
But you can set it
through the send
command in the Map Builder.
EasyTracker--
kind of a side point-- but the
EasyTracker now extends tracker.
So you can treat EasyTracker
just like you tracker you call
in get, set, and send.
And the EasyTracker for Android
will continue to
manage sessions as
it did in v2.
So there's still a parameter
that you can control that will
determine how long the app sits
in the background before
a session control flag start.
Go ahead.
ANDREW WALES: Yeah, I was going
to say so for people who
are using EasyTracker on Android
and v2 right now, to
handle session management, for
them there's probably no
noticeable change
in v3, right?
JIM COTUGNO: So the one
noticeable change is when they
first start--
no, I guess you're right.
So when the EasyTracker first
starts it will assume a new
session because whatever time
period you put in there will
have expired basically.
ANDREW WALES: I see.
But for those people who are not
using EasyTracker in v3,
they should know-- especially
this top point-- that the
tracker class will no longer
set session control flag to
start when the tracker
is created.
JIM COTUGNO: That's correct
and very important point.
And if you're not aware of that
you might be a little bit
concerned because your session
numbers won't quite look the
same as between v3 and v2.
For iOS, again, as part of this
alignment we wanted to
make all SDKs behave the same.
And so we removed the session
management code which was in
the GAI tracker class
from iOS.
Again, like in Android, we no
longer set the session control
parameter to start when the
tracker is first created.
If you need to do this manually,
which might be a
good idea, you can look
at hooking up to the
notifications.
UI application did
become active.
And we'll resign active.
And what you would do there
is, to become active, you
would look to see if a certain
length of time had passed,
which you would set up using
the will resign active
notification or call back.
And then you can decide to set
session, the session control
parameter, to start or not on
the next hit based on the
values you have there.
ANDREW WALES: For Android
users who are not using
EasyTracker but they do want the
session control, flag to
get set to start when the
app launches, for
example, is the way--
would one way to do that be the
subclass application in
Android and do it in
the [INAUDIBLE]?
JIM COTUGNO: Well remember, you
don't want to call set on
the tracker.
ANDREW WALES: Right.
Sorry.
Don't set it on the tracker.
But you might want to
set it on a screen
view map, for example.
JIM COTUGNO: Right.
So, yeah.
So your map that you passed in
would have it set or not.
ANDREW WALES: So let's take a
quick look at what's new with
Ecommerce in version
3 of the SDKs.
It's actually a pretty
small change.
Basically you need to--
whereas before you would
basically send your
transaction object in one hit,
you would kind of create this
transaction object and then add
items and then send it all
in one hit.
In v3 you need to make separate
send calls for each
transaction and item.
So the syntax is very much the
same as sending app views or
events in v3.
So the easiest way to do it is
to use Map Builder and then
you'd call create transaction,
add everything, all the
details there.
Build it.
Send it.
And then do the same thing for
your items, all of them.
One thing that, as always, make
sure that the transaction
ID in each item matches up to
the transaction ID that you
used in the transaction hit.
But other than that, all the
fields are the same.
It's just that you need to make
sure that you're calling
send for the transaction
and then also call send
individually for each item.
OK, cool.
So let's take some of
your questions.
So the first one, Jim, can
you please explain the
relationship between sessions,
session duration, and how
active users are determined?
JIM COTUGNO: That's kind
of a big question.
ANDREW WALES: It is
a loaded question.
JIM COTUGNO: It's a Universal
Analytics question, but I
guess I'll take a stab at kind
of explaining a little bit and
hopefully maybe we can get some
updates on the website
that really kind of goes
in this in depth.
But so, session is basically a
set of interactions a user has
with your application.
They can be considered like
a single visit to the
application and those sessions
will be made up of one or
more, what we call, hits or
beacons in Analytics.
The session duration is measured
more or less from the
time that passes between the
first hit is sent or is
generated and the last
hit is generated.
And then active users are
basically the number of users
that send one or more sessions
during the particular
reporting period in question.
So that's kind of the
simple answer.
ANDREW WALES: If session
duration is--
what would happen in
a session with one?
So you said that to get the
duration we look at the first
hit and the last hit to
get the duration.
But what happens if there's
only one in the session?
JIM COTUGNO: Well then the
duration is going to be zero.
ANDREW WALES: It's
set to zero.
OK.
JIM COTUGNO: So if you have
a lot of sessions that are
looking like they're zero
seconds in length--
ANDREW WALES: That's
what it is.
JIM COTUGNO: That might
be what's going on.
ANDREW WALES: OK.
Cool.
So next question.
Could calls, especially event
calls, be batched at dispatch
time in one single request?
JIM COTUGNO: We're
looking at doing
something like that, yes.
So I can't give you any sort
of commitment as to when or
how, but it's been on our
mind for a while.
Yeah.
ANDREW WALES: So maybe
coming soon.
Next question.
Is there a way to keep Real-Time
Analytics while
using a sample rate
of less than 100%?
JIM COTUGNO: Well, so Real-Time
Analytics takes the
same data that you'd send to the
websites for the reports
and just gives it to you a lot
more quickly than you would
get it otherwise.
So, your Real-Time Analytics
data should be very much the
same as your report data.
So as long as you have a large
enough sample, if your sample
rate's less than 100%, I think
Real-Time can still be useful.
All right, obviously, you're
going to have to scale the
numbers in your head, or
whatever, so we report the raw
numbers, we don't report
the sample numbers.
So, for example, if you see 10
and your sample rate is 10,
you could reasonably infer that
you have 100 users there
at that time.
ANDREW WALES: So basically, the
sample rate is going to
just limit the number of hits
that get sent from the client,
but the real time reporting
isn't going to--
it'll show all the hits that
make it but if your sample
rate is 50%, you're only going
to see one hit in real time
instead of two.
JIM COTUGNO: I guess the other
important thing to point out
here is that the sample
rate is actually
based on the visitor.
So a particular user or visitor
to your app will
either report all their
interactions or none of them.
So it's not like you'll see half
the events this user's
generated, you'll see them all
if the user's going to report
based on the sample rate.
ANDREW WALES: So, I have another
question here about
the new combined Google
Analytics Services SDK.
So with v3 we're sort of giving
you Analytics but also
Google Tag Manager together.
So the question here is, will
there also be an SDK version
without Google Tag Manager?
And they're concerned about the
size of that combined SDK.
JIM COTUGNO: So Google Tag
Manager and Google Analytics
are like one product, or
just two different
ways of doing things.
So we're not going to have a
separate SDK at this point.
So there will always--
the SDK going forward will
always include both Google Tag
Manager and Google Analytics.
I wouldn't worry too much
about the size.
If you're doing development in
iOS, for example, the Xcode
will strip out all the code
that you don't use.
So your actual final binary
will be smaller
than you would expect.
And if you're using something at
ProGuard in Android you'll
get the same benefit.
So even though the SDKs are
larger, your app code
shouldn't get larger
as a result.
It should be based-- as a matter
of fact, the iOS SDK,
for example, the v3 version is
actually smaller than the v2
version, even with the Google
Tag Manager merge.
So the end result's actually
better for you.
ANDREW WALES: Cool.
All right.
Jim, any idea on when real-time
events will be added
to app properties?
JIM COTUGNO: That's another
one I'd say, yes,
we want to do that.
We're working on it.
I cannot give you any sort
of commitment as to time.
ANDREW WALES: So maybe
this will come soon.
Maybe.
I think we've got time
for maybe one more.
And this is a good one.
Jim, this is a plea to you.
Can you stop changing function
names every two months?
JIM COTUGNO: We'll
try our best.
Yes.
I do apologize for the
fast-paced changes that we've
gone through in the last year.
But I'm hopeful--
cross our fingers here--
I'm hopeful this is the last
time we change names, method
names, like this.
ANDREW WALES: And now at least
when you're moving from one
library to another, for example,
if you got from
Android to the web, you should
see more consistency.
JIM COTUGNO: Yes.
And even Android to iOS, they're
more consistent now
than they were before.
ANDREW WALES: Cool.
Awesome.
Cool.
So that brings us to the
end of this edition
of Behind the Code.
I wanted to pass on
some resources
to everybody watching.
So we have Getting Started
Guides for the v3 SDKs for
both Android and iOS.
There's a link there.
It's basically
developers.google.com/analytics.
We also have Migration Guides,
and these guides cover
migrating from v2 to v3,
or even v1 to v3, so
go check that out.
We have a Mobile App
Analytics Forum.
There's a link here.
There's a lot of good questions
and answers on there.
I know Jim is an active
participant in that forum from
time to time.
So there's a lot of good
insight there.
And there is also, if you're
willing to send measurement
protocol parameters in these
SDKs, so we showed you how to
do that using that
ampersand syntax.
We do have a whole parameter
reference that shows you all
the different protocol
parameters.
So you can go check
that out as well.
And with that, thank you
so much for joining us.
That brings us to the
end of the show.
Feel free to reach out to
us on Google+ and we'll
catch you next time.